the video from a mobile phone might be
shaky but it conveys just how come the
gun man is as he shoots down the street
in Halle and watch how people take cover
in the distance
eyewitnesses say one woman a passerby
was shot near a synagogue a spokesperson
for the local Jewish community says an
attacker tried to shoot his way into the
synagogue where around 80 people have
gathered on Yom Kippur the holiest
Jewish holiday and then threw a grenade
into the cemetery next to it
Germany's foreign minister Heiko Maas
has tweeted it hits us in the heart that
a synagogue was shot at on the Day of
Atonement
we must all act against anti-semitism in
our country elsewhere in the town one
person was reportedly killed when a
Turkish kebab shop was attacked this man
was inside on Taba
kazeem vino fowl Austin I was standing
at the entrance and saw an elderly woman
passed by and behind her there was
suddenly this man wearing a helmet and
military-style clothes he was holding a
gun and wearing a balaclava and then he
tried to throw what looked like a hand
grenade but it bounced off the doorframe
and exploded right in front of this
elderly woman with a very loud bang and
then he raised the gun and started
shooting as police warned people to stay
indoors they confirmed they'd arrested
one person we have at least two crime
scenes one person died as the result of
a shooting in the area of Ludwig
vocalist Rosser and another one in the
area of Humboldt Strasse we first
received information that there was one
terrorism suspect who was armed have
since been suggestions so there could
have been more people involved but
that's not confirmed at this point the
suspect was wearing a head camera and
the attacks were live streamed on the
Internet the gunman speaking English in
German calls himself a Holocaust denier
also denouncing feminism and mass
immigration he calls himself a loser
after the synagogue attack doesn't go to
plan before moving on to the kebab
restaurant a shooting was also reported
in the town of Landsberg 20 minutes
drive from Haller Germany's tried to
fight a resurgence of right wing and
neo-nazi extremism in recent years
including the firebombing of synagogues
the investigation into the Haller
attacks has now been taken over by
federal anti-terrorism prosecutors